-Welcome to the show!
-Hello.
Hi. Thank you having me.
-How are you?
-Good, good. Yes.
-I'm so happy you're here.
-Yes.
Thank you for having me.
-Happy Halloween.
Happy Halloween, everyone.
-Happy Halloween, everyone
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you have any plans?
Will you do anything?
-No, I'm gonna be at
my mom's apartment,
giving candy to little people.
-Well, that's something, yeah.
-It's something.
-You'll be giving out candy.
And then, you grew up in city.
So is that --
Would you just sort of, like
go, like, down the apartment
hallway and whatnot?
-That's exactly --
Yeah, I grew up in a building --
I grew up, like,
in a multiple-story building
So it's weird, yeah.
'Cause I see, if I watch, like
American pop-culture movie
about Halloween,
it's in a neighborhood,
it's on a street.
But I did it in a building
with a row of apartments.
Not a bad thing.
Just different.
-Yeah, I mean, I assume you,
like, knock out way more.
I would have to go, like -
I'd have to go to five towns
to knock out as many.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I had, like, sugar-intake
problems growing up.
-Yes?
-Yeah, I was --
-I know you have --
Do you have a favorite
Halloween costume
from over the years?
-I have, like,
a couple of favorites.
Like, I did Yugi
from "Yu-Gi-Oh" one year.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A couple of "Yu-Gi-Oh"
enthusiasts here.
[ Laughter ]
I did a -- okay.
I, like, was on the Spider-Man
enthusiastic tint one year
-Yeah, okay.
-So, I just got the outfit
But then, that, rightfully
seemed kind of douchey
or something.
Like, to just wear the outfi
is kind of, like, weird.
-Yeah, that's a little
show-off-y, yeah.
-No -- Yeah --
you see, okay.
But then, that was the year --
That was
"Spider-Man: Turn Off The Dark
was on Broadway that year.
-Yeah.
-And that was
the Broadway version,
not the celebrated Tom Holland
highly profitable version.
This was -- This was, like -
They had a lot of accidents.
A lot of people were, like
getting very hurt on it.
-A lot -- Yeah
There was, like, sort of
a trapeze-y
type Spider-Man show,
and there were some injuries
-They were not real Spider-Men
-Yeah.
-They were real --
They were stuntmen
with very real bones.
So I just -- just threw a cast
on and some crutches and -
[ Laughter ]
-So, you were Spider-Man -
-I was Spider-Man on Broadway.
[ Laughter ]
And that --
And this is the bit
where I really should
have a picture now,
and I don't know why
I don't have one.
And I was so, like, I don'
know, confident about it.
I have a friend
from high school here with me.
And I was like,
"Remember when I did the
Spider-Man, like,
on Broadway thing?"
He has no idea
what I'm talking about.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I wonder if people saw it
and they jumped ahead to,
one, you were doing
Spider-Man on Broadway,
or if they were like,
"Oh, that poor guy
broke his leg before Halloween
and he's still toughing it out."
-Yeah, so it was
a little bit of that.
It was also the fact
that it was spandex.
And I don't know
how many spandex enthusiasts
we have in the audience,
but that's a weird thing.
-Yeah.
-And there's body parts
that are not used to that.
[ Laughter ]
And so I was figuring that out
the whole night.
-Yeah, yeah, that's a lot.
-Yes.
-I'm so glad you worked throug
that Halloween.
-Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Appreciate it.
Yes.
-This is wonderful.
One of the people
you're working with, who was
in that clip is Joel Edgerton.
-Yes, he's be on here.
-Yeah, he's one of
my favorite guys.
Was he as much fun to work wit
as I would think?
-A lot of fun,
an extraordinary actor.
The director of this movie
Joel Edgerton,
the cinematographer,
they're all Australian.
Ben Mendelsohn,
another great actor.
-Yeah, Aussie!
-Aussie in the house!
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
And so I felt like
I was jumping into this
creative Australian circus
And -- And Joel and I,
Falstaff and Prince Hal,
in the movie,
they're quite close.
So we tried to get quite close
in real life and hung out a lot.
We did a Q&A recently.
I got in trouble
'cause I said I'd never gone out
with somebody that old before.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And that was, like,
no shade or anything.
But Joel is 94 --
No, no, no, Joel is --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, anyway.
It is what it is.
-It is what it is.
Can't take it back.
A lot of people have commented
on your haircut in the movie
-Yeah.
-That's not a wig, right?
That's the real deal.
-That's real.
-Are you --
Very appropriate for the film.
Are you happy it's grown out
-Yeah, I'm happy
to be done with it.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, the big lesso
is, like, nobody cares.
And that's the lesson of life,
I guess.
-Yeah.
-But I don't know.
For things of hair,
personality, whatever,
you think people are --
No one cares.
-Yeah.
-No one cares.
-I would imagine, though,
you have a haircut like this
and you're on set,
and it's, you know,
all these incredible costumes,
these incredible actors,
and they all have
their hair and wardrobe,
and then the minute
you walk off the set,
you must have a moment like,
"Oh, this is a weird haircut."
-Oh, no, no, no.
I have, like, an extraordinary
hat collection that --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
So, I got good at that.
Also, like, isn't it --
Maybe I shouldn't even say this.
But isn't it true, like --
You know what?
Never mind, never mind,
never mind.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's funny, there are som
people where I would push on it,
and already with you, I'm like
"I think
you're making the right call."
-Yes.
-Yeah.
Whatever it is, I think
you're making the right call
This is very exciting.
You're gonna be in
"Little Women."
This is a reunion.
-"Little Women"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And the co-stars --
-And the woman warriors!
Okay. Sorry.
-Saoirse Ronan, Greta Gerwig
who you worked with
on "Lady Bird."
And we've talked -- I've talke
with some of your cast mates
from that film about how Greta
as a director,
tries to make everybody
feel very close and welcome.
-At ease, yeah.
-At ease.
They wear name tags.
And I heard she had
sort of a dance party.
Or I guess a dance rehearsal..
-Yes, yes.
-...for "Little Women."
How did that come about?
-Well, there's two big
dance sequences in the film.
One's with Meg March,
who's played by Emma Watson,
and one's with Jo,
who's played by Saoirse and --
Saoirse Ronan,
should say her whole name.
And, basically,
as an icebreaker, as a way to,
you know, lose our masks
and our shields of defense
of insecurity,
Greta had us
do this dance class
in this big room.
And being the only guy
was not the deficit.
There maybe was no deficit
But I will say, like, I grew u
on "Harry Potter" in some way.
I grew up seeing those movies.
So that first time
seeing Emma Watson --
This is gonna be weird
for her to see now.
[ Laughter ]
But that was, like,
definitely a weird moment,
and I had to work past that.
-You worked past it, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Do you think at the time --
-It was tons of therapy.
It was like a lot of therapy
but that's fine.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think a lot of time,
the first time people
see Emma Watson,
they then have to at least
do, like, a year of therapy.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Depending on how big
of a "Harry Potter" fan you are,
it might even be longer.
-Yeah, I can't like --
-Do you think --
-I'm ready to wholeheartedly
agree with everything
you say up here.
That was dangerous.
I was like --
I don't know
if I agree with that.
-This is -- It's very exciting
to have you here
and so great
to finally meet you.
I've been a fan
for a long time.
-Yeah.
-Timothée Chalamet, everybody.